In this video, I will show you five of
the best edges and trading models that
you can use as a trader. And I'm not
talking about some vague concepts or
geometric shapes that I cherry-picked
from another charts. I'm talking about
five repetitive and predictable behavior
that are vastly documented by
institutional-level
academical research. And they have
persistently occurred in [music]
financial markets over the last decade.
Five of the so-called structural edges.
[music] We are not talking about a
short-term inefficiency, but five
behavior that are structural because of
how the plumbing of financial markets
[music] works. And that you, as a
trader, could potentially extract
real [music] alpha. Of course, this is
not financial advice. It's only for
educational purpose. Now, I have been
involved in financial markets for
multiple years. Some know me as a
professional scalper, as I won multiple
podiums in the most famous competition,
the Robbins Cup, or in the CME Equity
Cup, or because, unlike many guru, I
traded live countless times. And I have
literally tried every trading strategy
you can name. And I have selected for
you both what allow me to build a
considerable amount of my wealth, but
also the results of years and years and
money invested in [music] extensive
quantitative research and learning
constantly approaches and [music]
strategies from hedge fund managers,
bank floor traders, and other
professionals. Here's the five model
that I will [music] show you. Two
long-term models on the stock market,
one intraday [music] model on the
equities market, one option model,
and one cryptocurrency smart DCA. And
you are probably asking yourself,
[music] why I need five approaches?
Shouldn't I choose only one? Because the
truth is, unlike retail traders that
typically only trust one strategy, one
model, and one guru, and basically
choose a side like at the stadium,
professionals in finance don't choose
side. They just follow the money. And
there is many ways to follow the money.
stops working tomorrow, [music] what
would you do? You may be panic, strategy
hope, revenge trading. If instead you
use many and diversified models, you
will be more independent in changes
[music]
in market regime, and you will get a way
smoother equity line. And you will see
the more you will scale in trading
profession, the more you will realize
how important it is. Just like we are
planning in the hedge fund that we are
in process of building, to think in
terms of alpha, beta, and risk-adjust
[music] return. So, without further ado,
let's meet these five models. Let's dive
deep into my top five favorite
structural edge. Here we will not talk
about guru, no hope trading, no mentor,
just data, okay? And this is my message
to the trading industry, okay? Instead
of trying to replicate the performance
of your favorite guru, or trust blindly,
okay, the strategies that use the work
that you should do, it's called a
research and validation process. And
this apply to everything. If you are an
investor, if you are an intraday trader,
if you want to trade stocks, if you want
to trade crypto, you should research and
you should validate what you are
applying. Also, because market change,
there is one concept called alpha decay.
And as the reason to help you in doing
this, I'm providing for free here five
structural edge that are supported by
extensive academical research, data, and
track record from the biggest
institutions in the world. Let's start
with the first one. The concept of
earning surprise drift. The earning
surprise drift, the PAAD, the behavioral
under reaction anomaly, post quarterly
announcement, is one of the oldest edge
in the stock market, and it's proven by
a lot of test. Now, this edge here works
because there is one concept in the
institutions and in the hedge fund
called alpha execution. So, when you
have a sudden change in information in
the market because maybe one stock beat
the expectations in the earnings by two,
three times, by 40, 50, 60%. Okay? This
information needs time to be priced in
because the market participants are not
willing to suffer a huge amount of
slippage. So, they will fractionalize
their order, and one example of this,
one alpha execution method that I was
also discussing with Freddy, one
ex-market maker, is the VWAP. Okay? So,
they put algorithmic in in the market
where they will buy the stocks they are
interested in because there was a sudden
shift in fundamentals at one specific
price. They will accumulate, okay?
Without rushing and running after the
price where you pay a lot of slippage,
okay? And when you have an average
feeling price that is not so good, okay?
The earning surprise drift represent one
of the oldest, most robust market
anomaly. It's firstly documented by Ball
and Brown in the 1968,
and it shows that stock with high
standardized unanticipated earning
continue to drift upward for up to 60
days, while negative surprise stocks
drift downwards. Investor anchored to
previous estimates suffer from limited
attention during busy earning season,
leading to slow information diffusion
and delayed price adjustment.
Under-reaction is reinforced by
transaction cost, short sale constraint,
negative surprise small gap, and
liquidity limits. These include also
slippage, preventing institutional
traders from instantly correcting the
mispricing. And this is where the edge
for retail works, okay? And this is why
it's present for multiple years. So, you
start with an hypothesis and you build
the structural mechanics. Now, let's go
on this. This is one chart that show the
spread, okay, for a sample of positive
earnings, the good news and the bad
news. And as you can see, the stock
drift in the direction of the earnings
in the next 60 day. This is day one,
this is 60 day, okay? The spread is
relevant, the spread is 4%, okay? And
for 60 days, 4% in a single stock it's a
lot. Specifically, if you also do
statistical analysis on the stock that
you are picking. If you want to check by
yourself, you are a nerd and you want to
read, go to check this verified academic
research from Kaczmarek and Zaremba,
Beyond the Last Surprise, Reviving Post
Earnings Announcement Drift with Machine
Learning. This one is beautiful from
2025. And the second one from Bernard
and Thomas of the '89, one of the oldest
one, Post Earnings Announcement Drift,
Delayed Price Response. Let's go on the
second edge. The second edge is my
favorite, okay? Everyone knows me for
the IVB. I validated this from an
institutional perspective with multiple
platform also on Python to show that the
stocks have an upside skew and they have
a structural drift of the battle of the
first 30 minutes. We also received a
test and audit from an ex-market maker,
Matteo Conti, that did a super extensive
test on this behavior and validated this
also. By the way, if you want this
flowchart, you can click the link in the
description because I will share it in
the Telegram channel, completely for
free. The core edge, the initial volume
breakout or the initial balance drift,
and there is a huge amount of literature
also without implementing volume of the
opening range breakout, so just using
price. Okay. The initial balance
represent the high and low price
established during the first 30 minutes
of a regular cash trading. Volatility
contraction during this first half hour
often revolves in explosive volume
confirmed directional breakout runs that
hold strong predictive power for the
rest of the session. Now, let's start on
the assumption of without considering
volume, just considering if the Nasdaq
have a structural drift on the upside
and if the opening range of the first 30
minutes hold predicted value over the
coin flip. And we can see that we have a
skew of 13.5%
okay. So, measuring the session after
the breakout that close above this
breakout, it's already blindly without
order flow, without option flow, without
logic of the strategy confirmation 13.5%
okay. So, with the risk to reward okay
of one of one measuring the same amount
okay, we have a skew of 13.5% of being
right just from this valuation okay.
Then I did extensive test also with the
quant, we saw how this edge perform in
the last 5-10 years and how you can take
both side because you can also implement
the short side okay that is more strong
but you should be able to analyze the
gamma regime because in this one option
flow comes really handy. And I gave also
the verified academical literature, the
one of Andrea Barbon, Carlo Zarattini,
Andrew Aziz, profitable day trading
strategy for the US equity markets. The
founder of this, Toby Crabel, that
started with the opening range breakout
without implementing volume, but it's
already profitable with this logic. And
the one of Holberg, assessing the
profitability of intraday opening range
breakout strategy. Consider order flow
for timing, this is what Getting a
direction validated by statistical
research and then timing my entry with
order flow and option flow for
directional pressure. Let's go on the
third edge, asymmetrical information and
regulatory filing. Politician tracking,
okay? Member of Congress frequently
trade stocks in sector directly impacted
by committees they sit on. Speaker
Emerita Nancy Pelosi's family portfolio
has achieved legendary status,
outperforming nearly every hedge fund
with 54% gain in 2024 and a 65% gain in
2023, primarily through leverage call
options on high growth tech stocks. Now,
the hypothesis, key politician have
access to non-public forward-looking
information regarding federal contract,
regulatory changes, subsidies, and
antitrust decision before they are made
public. Structural mechanics, while the
Stock Act of 2012 mandates trade
disclosure within 45 days. Copy trading
the most active and powerful committee
members create a structural alpha edge.
These politician possess asymmetric
insight into macroeconomic policy policy
shift like the CHIPS Act or the green
energy subsidies. Now, to avoid
cherry-picking the politician, we test
Nancy Pelosi, Brian Higgins, and Mark
Green portfolio. And as you can see, we
compare this with the buy and hold on
S&P 500, and you can see the result of
this equity line comparing Nancy Pelosi,
Brian Hicks, and Mark Green to the S&P
500 results. You can see that Nancy
Pelosi is the best performer. Okay. And
we can go on the verified academical
literature. This one of 2011, abnormal
return from the common stock investment
of member of the US House. And this is
why in the 2012 they created the STOCK
Act exactly for what this paper was
demonstrating. And the one of Fisher,
talking stocks of democracies, abnormal
returns of high-profile member of
Congress. This is from 2025. So,
remember that the edge are not only
price, volume, okay, or data. They can
also be informational edge in timing.
And this edge can be taken as a
structural alpha even if there is this
delay of 45 days between the release of
the information and the actual result of
the price. Let's go on the next one, the
option premium harvesting. And this is
also another structural edge,
capitalizing on the systematic
volatility risk premium, the VRP.
Abstract, option premium harvesting is
the systematic selling of
out-of-the-money option to capture the
volatility risk premium. The volatility
risk premium exists because implied
volatility, listen closely, implied
volatility, IV, is structurally higher
than ex-post realized volatility, the
RV. Hypothesis,
implied volatility represent a risk
insurance premium that institutional
buyers are willing to overpay to hedge
their downside risk, allowing option
sellers to collect a persistent yield.
The risk premium is a structural
compensation for taking on tail risk
because markets are crash phobic.
Out-of-the-money puts trade at a premium
that significantly exceed their
mathematical probability of expiring in
the money. Here you can see the test,
okay, of the last 12 months of the
difference between implied volatility
and realized volatility. You will see
with your own eyes that realized
volatility it's more often than not
lower than implied volatility. And here
are two papers that I find amazing, the
current rule from 2009 variance risk
premium and the Oleg Bondarenko, why are
put options so expensive?
The last edge, this one is the edge that
gave me the most amount of results
during the years because it was really
early in the blockchain adoption and in
the Bitcoin cycle.
And now there are a lot of papers that
are coming out about the smart DCA on
the crypto space. This is the blockchain
intelligence model. So, optimizing
Bitcoin accumulation using the MVRV zeta
score versus the buy and hold. Now, this
one it's a simplification to make it
quantitative. I have my own model that
have even better performance than this
that is based on multiple set of
mathematical condition before pressing
buy and before selling the Bitcoin. A
standard buy and hold strategy expose
investor to maximum drawdown exceeding
80% and if you study the retracement
from the all-time high of Bitcoin, you
notice. The blockchain intelligence
model use the market value to realize
value, the MVRV zeta score to identify
macro market cycles and adjust
allocation size dynamically, buying
heavily at capitulation and reducing
risk gradually at euphoria. And if you
study the biggest portfolio in the
market, you will notice that this is
exactly how the big whale of the market
move and you can monitor this by
checking their holding activity. The
hypothesis, public blockchains provide a
transparent, real-time record of
investor cost basis, the realized value.
Standardizing the difference between
market value and realized value reveals
the extreme deviation from fair network
valuation. Structural mechanic, because
Bitcoin lack traditional cash flow
anchors, price cycles are driven
entirely by purely behavioral
reflexivity. The MVRV zeta score
standardized this psychological swing,
flagging absolute capitulation and
extreme euphoria. Empirical equity line,
this is the comparison between the
dynamic the one on the MVRV, the static
DCA, and the buy and hold approach. And
below, we can see the Grobity and Nazman
Sandretto 2026 using on-chain data to
predict Bitcoin cycles, and the Nazman
research paper about using on-chain data
to predict cryptocurrency cycles. I hope
you find a lot of value in this video.
Test these models and let me know if you
find any edge. I hope it helps you to
realize the important of diversification
and the importance of starting with an
hypothesis.